The plum pudding model of an atom
was one of the most widely accepted models
all over the world
for understanding the structure of the atom!
However,
several experiments performed by scientists
to study the atomic structure
showed astonishingly different results.
They were contradicting the plum pudding model.
This led many scientists
all over the globe to reconsider the structure of an atom
and study it again.
Around the year nineteen hundred and eleven,
a British physicist Ernst Rutherford,
carried out the famous Gold foil experiment.
He did this to understand the structure of an atom!
The experiment was carried out by Rutherford along with
Hans Geiger and Ernest Marsden.
The experiment he performed
was a breakthrough in the field of chemistry
which helped him understand the structure of an atom
in a more accurate manner.
This is how the setup of his experiment looked like!
As we can see here,
he used a source of alpha particles,
locked in a lead container with a very small slit.
This ensured that the alpha particles
only came out through a small opening
and travelled in a straight line.
But why did he select alpha particles in the first place?
Well the alpha particles were having high energy
and were heavier as well.
So if we say the atom is like a
pudding of positively charged particles
with electrons embedded in it,
then the particles will pass straight through it.
This is obvious because the heavier particles
will pierce through the lighter pudding structure
of the atom and pass through it.
This is what Rutherford thought!
For this reason,
their greater mass and energy compared to the protons
made him choose alpha particles for the experiment.
Next he used a very thin gold foil
on which the alpha particles would bombard.
Why did he choose a gold foil?
Well,
a really thin gold foil was estimated to contain
approximately one thousand atoms.
Lesser the atoms,
more convenient the experiment would be!
Lastly,
are we able to locate this circular band with a gap here?
What could this be?
Well,
this is a screen.
A fluorescent screen
that would help us detect the radiation.
That means,
the screen will glow or emit fluorescent light
whenever alpha particles will hit it.
So this is how the track of alpha particles can be traced.
Now we are all set to understand
how the experiment worked!
The alpha particles were emitted from the element
present in this box.
These directly hit the gold foil!
Now what should happen ideally?
As we know, the Thomson’s model suggested
that an atom is a sphere of positive charge
with negative electrons embedded inside it.
That means it is expected that the alpha particles
will pass right through the atoms
and hit the detector straight!
And why so?
Because the mass of alpha particles
is heavier than the mass of positive charges.
That means they should directly hit the atom
and move ahead, through it.
Only a very small deviation
would probably be acceptable in this case.
But is this what he observed?
Not really,
he was astonished to get unexpected results!
What results did he get?
He found that most of the fast moving alpha particles
passed straight through the foil and hit the detector.
However,
some particles got deflected by small angles.
And lastly to his astonishment,
few alpha particles also rebounded.
Now how can this be possible?
These three observations made Rutherford think
that the plum pudding model is not really correct.
Based on the conclusions he had,
he put forward the new hypothesis
explaining the structure of atoms!
What were his conclusions?
Let us have a look at the conclusions by Rutherford
followed by the new atomic model put forth by him
in the next video!